let's talk tim mcgraw by the numbers the
country music superstar has won
three grammys 16 academy of country
music awards and 14
country music association awards he's
also sold 50 million albums around the
world with 43 number one singles oh and
he's about to top those numbers with his
new album out today called here on earth
and here on earth there's another big
number sangeeta wanted to remind him of
the number 25 as in his 25th wedding
anniversary to faith hell
tim next year is your 25th wedding
anniversary
what's the difference for 25. next year
yes
i do want to scare you yeah no next year
your diamond anniversary it's a big deal
are you
do you have plans in place i'm not yet
but i got to come up with something
don't i got to have a good plan
i got to figure something really good
out for our 10th anniversary i built a
at our farm i built the knights of
arabia
tent with a bed and a movie screen
and a dinner table and fires bonfires
all outside of it so we spent the night
up in the knights of arabia attending
watch
foreign film i'll come up with something
good do i want
[Music]
you teased the whole damn sure do video
on your instagram
uh what is that video and is what how
did faith react
to the video she loved it you know what
it was
oddly enough a fan had put that video
together
and i saw it and i thought it was so
special and so cool that i wanted to
just
add a little bit of that of damn sure
due to it just to see how it would turn
out
and it worked out perfectly so i i owe
that all to a fan who just put a great
video it's amazing
grab my phone from my pocket
and i called mama cue to the tears man i
at this video the
song i call my mom right after her i'm a
mom
and i always like to get the dad's
perspective when you get married
your wife becomes this mom to your
daughter your three daughters
what is that journey for you to watch
that happen
it's incredible i mean you know to see
the bond that they have and the
relationship that they have
i mean i grew up with my mom and two
sisters so without much of a dad around
so
my my daughters have grown up to be
strong
independent um outspoken they don't take
any
from anybody really good
solid girls and and they're good friends
to their friends and
and their their good daughters to their
parents and
and i just thank god every day that they
had their mama's rolled off
i have two daughters too and you know
what i'm learning more from them than
i've ever have and especially the time
like this
what have they taught you or at least is
there one of them that's more similar to
you
i don't know that there's one that's
more similar to hard-headedness they got
a double dose of the head
so they all are pretty hard-headed
because their mom and dad both are
pretty hard-headed when we argue with
them and we wonder why they're
we ask them how come you're so
hard-headed they just look at us and
laugh
[Applause]
27 years this is your 16th studio album
there's always when you create new music
and content there's always that one
person or maybe there's a bunch of
people whose opinion matters the most to
you who's
that person to you well my wife first i
want her to hear it and i don't
get her opinion and we don't always
agree you know and stuff i mean yeah
different musical taste but i have a
handful of people
that are in the industry and people that
are not in the industry in that
buddy of mine i went to college with you
know just a few people that are don't
really
even listen to music that much and most
the time they're pretty dead on
sometimes yeah sometimes i miss too